1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ils recevront quatre
nouveaux candidats les aventuriers sans
peur farouche et courageux et ils vont
devoir braver les dangers du fort s'ils
veulent repartir avec le trésor une
forte aux quarts
[Musique]
e
bonjour à tous je m'appelle florence jeu
viennent de la région paca je suis et
sérieuse de toboggans aquatiques et je
collectionne les dessous de verre alors
moi j'ai ltn qu'on en voit qu'elle
espère que la laisse
bon alors bonjour moi si jean-yves juin
de l'île d'oléron et je suis champion
poitou charentes de beyblade
enfin je suis deuxième le premier
c'était loïc et mon rêve c'est de
rencontrer cyril drevet j'ai la chimay
la chimay bleue
bonjour à tous ce mois c'est richard je
suis le mari de la petite florence je
suis sapeur-pompier volontaire mais
également militant fn quoi il ya un
problème avec les pompes bien bonjour
moi c'est joueur du grenier et je suis
un peu obligé d'être là vu que c'est mon
émission
c'est perdu il parle d'un bal est juste
là je quand même pas seul à le voir si
bien tout le monde est prêt tout d'abord
bonjour à tous vous êtes donc paré à
affronter les nombreux dangers du fort
taux car vous êtes arrivées de très loin
venir jusqu'ici
j'imagine que maintenant vous allez me
parler de votre association ça oui
alors nous on est venu pour les
batailles de noël en fait on aimerait
rouler des patins aux paraplégiques
enfin on aimerait qu'ils aient des
patins qui roule parce que voilà on
comprend pas pourquoi eux ils
passeraient pas un joyeux noël
voilà nous n'a envie de faire bouger les
choses pour les handicapés on veut que
ça bouge à faut que ça bouge bah faut
que ça roule pour sa route
voilà ça bouge eva c'est parfait je vous
propose maintenant de sélectionner la
personne la plus intelligente d'entre
vous qui va répondre aux énigmes du père
fouras hockey combien j'ai doit en tout
non mais ta gueule
3 bravo jean yves c'est quoi c'est ça ma
poule
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour excusez moi je n'ai pas
moins de visiteurs ici donc laissez moi
vous raconter une histoire
les jeux vidéo adaptés de jeux télévisés
toulouse et ça existe qui veut gagner
des millions
et la roue de la fortune intervilles
même koh lanta mais ça a ses raisons et
l'énigme c'est donc si on remonte
beaucoup plus loin on entend même sur
les taux premier support à une famille
en or et c'est aux parties par exemple
il était donc évident qu'une émission
avec autant de succès que fort boyard
est aussi droit c'est la natation
regarder toutes ces merdes des cahiers
de vacances des jeux de société et plein
de jeux vidéo bon je peux la voir ma
[ __ ] d'énigmes en ta gueule je parle à
mes hallucinations phare briard quel que
soit votre âge vous avez forcément ce
que c'est l'émission ayant commencé en
1990 avec une diffusion ininterrompue
jusqu'à ce jour
le principe est simple des candidats
rentrent dans un fort pour y gagner de
l'argent mais pour cela ils vont devoir
trouver les clés du trésor et répondre à
des aînés et impôts d'énigmes de
l'abandon haute une vie insipide
j'aimerais
de manière rapide cet immense sensation
de vide ne me laissait pas si si je me
suicide qui était alors oiseaux bec
hirondelles règle pas répond sa solitude
oui oui oui il est tout à fait tout à
fait c'était ça la bonne réponse la
solitude la clé
bon vous les gestes intimes avec vous
oui les jeux sur fort boyard on l'a dit
y'en a plein et sur plein de support et
je suis assez fier de vous dire que je
les ai tous
il m'en faut peu bref on en a même sur
console portable comme par exemple fort
boyard sur game boy color un jeu archi
classique vous enchaînerez des mini
donjon en mode plateforme à la recherche
de clés voilà donc bien rien à dire si
ce n'est que ça n'intéresse personne
les personnages sont tous les mêmes n'y
a absolument aucune différence c'est le
genre de jeu qu'on a déjà vu mille fois
où on a juste foutu un look de fort
boyard sur un jeu de plateforme qui
était déjà avant et je dirai juste toute
chose c'est que j'aurais aimé qu'ils
m'aident plus d'énergie dans la
maniabilité du jeu plutôt que de trouver
un moyen de faire remuer les nibards de
laboeuf et donc du coup enfin je fais ça
cinq minutes encore et je passe à la
suite on trouve aussi dans la liste des
jeux un peu originaux fort boyard
millénium sur pc je ne vais rien dire
dessus parce qu'il s'agit là d'un tomb
raider lie tout à fait banale pour
l'époque ni bon ni mauvais ici on sort
complètement du cadre de l'émission télé
puisque le jeu vous demande d'aller
sauver votre copain ou votre copine qui
s'est fait enlever alors que vous étiez
tranquillement en train de tourner votre
prochaine vidéo pour la catégorie 500
public de pornhub donc pas d'épreuve
mais des séries de salles chacune rempli
d'énigmes et de puzzles ou on y
affrontera notamment des magiciens
démoniaque et où recevra l'aide de père
fouras qui comme beaucoup de personnes
âgées a des soucis de figurines et a
visiblement excusez moi monsieur fouras
je pense que vous vous pisser dessus là
non pas du tout c'est de la poudre
magique excusez moi mais quand on
réfléchit au fond le plus logique serait
quand même de faire un jeu qui suivent
scrupuleusement le jeu télévisé comme ça
t'as pas besoin de te faire chier à un
vente et ajuste à adapter et la bei a
plus qu'à se baisser pour en ramasser et
c'est fort boyard sur pc après avoir
choisi le nombre de joueurs est votre
couleur on a donc droit à un jeu qu'on
puisse y attend pour un jeu sur fort
boyard c'est à dire les épreuves du fort
et même en plus le bonus on a droit à
des scènes en fmv l'illusion est
parfaite
ainsi qu'aux passages clés de l'émission
comme évidemment forcément le passage de
la vie [ __ ] ils ont fait péter le
budget la de new york ont peur de toute
la france en réduction d'au moins 80%
contre beauvais cotation chez gilles
effets spéciaux il veut surfer
enfin donc après évidemment lé phases de
gameplay sont constitués des épreuves du
fort alors déjà je sais pas si c'est mon
jeu qui a buggé si j'ai fait une
mauvaise installe aussi c'est normal
mais dès que j'arrête de bouger quelques
secondes genre pour réfléchir
le jeu s'est dit que c'était une bonne
idée de te répéter les consignes en
boucle pour vous les meilleurs partout
ouais vous savez pour vous aider genre
là ça va je bouge mais dès que j'arrête
de bouger les meilleurs parcours trouve
le meilleur parcours et les épreuves
justement tu galères tout le temps parce
que tout le jeu se joue à la souris et
les plus vieux d'entre vous se
souviendront des jeux qui se jouer comme
ça mais je veux dire qu'est ce que je
dois faire avec ma souris je dois faire
des rouges d'aller vers l'avant vers
l'arrière d'un clic et soit pas cliquer
qu'est ce que je dois faire
effectivement
je l'arête avec soi alors avec ma [ __ ]
je rêve de me dire de bien jauger alors
je sais même pas sur quel bouton appuyer
ce serait tellement plus simple aux
claviers mais non évidemment oh mais
qu'est ce qui se passe bordel quand même
marque cette épreuve encore qu'est ce
qui fait mon personnage là aux
actionnaires bref donc j'ai rien d'autre
à ajouter
il ya le passage avec les maîtres du
temps qui d'ailleurs déconne
complètement parce que j'ai eu cinq fois
le même jeux d'affilée et c'est comme ça
elle est guerrier puis auront sept
services publics
puis les énigmes et enfin la salle du
trésor
11000 745 euros waouh on en 96 cd francs
ah merde mais c'est nul à chier en fait
bien pendant que votre petit collègue
répond aux questions du père fougasse
passons maintenant à la première épreuve
il va falloir trouver parmi vous une
personne pleine de perspicacité
[ __ ] moi j'ai rien ramené je suis
désolé pottinger régnant à rien de
prendre alors ça sera richard les sharks
et moi tout à fait oui bien se voir une
porte
attends je suis sapeur pompier m'a
laissé partir les portes je les ouvre
pas je vais j'ai fait installer vous
wade briques hard et qu'est ce que tu
vois le porte fenêtre rien il ya un
caméraman et un cameraman c'est
peut-être lui qui a la clé est ce que
tout est ok c'est pas lui c'est pas lui
il ya quoi d'autre dans la salle via un
ordinateur et un ordinateur et ses
marques et press start pour commencer je
fais quoi
mais bon j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé ça
c'est forcément l'ordinateur je pense
que s'il est au milieu c'est pas pour
rien eh ben je vais presse le starter
je connaissais je sais tu dis ça c'est
pour lancer la partie test de la vidéo
agl je passe donc au jeu suivant et déjà
je dois vous dire qu'en ne vende jdg on
n'a jamais autant galéré à installer un
jeu que tu sois pour fort boyard le défi
ou fort boyard millénium ces deux jeux
ont été édités par la société microïds
mais ce troisième jeu lui sorti en 2006
et nommé simplement fort boyard le jeu a
été édité par mindscape sociétés ayant
fermé ses portes en 2011
et comme pour beaucoup de jeux de
l'époque il faut une clé cd pour y jouer
sauf que visiblement mindscape aurait
oublié de mettre les clés cd dans les
boîtes du jeu
c'est ironique qu'ils aient oublié la
clé dans un jeu fort boyard
[Musique]
quand on a fait ça du coup pour y jouer
mais il fallait appeler le service
technique pour avoir une clé mais ces
services techniques il a fermé
maintenant [ __ ] donc fort boyard le
jeu même principe que pour le défi
puisqu'il s'agit là tout bêtement un
nouveau des épreuves du fort sauf que
nous sommes passés au monde merveilleux
de la 3d
après c'est pas moche pour un jeu
français sorti en 1996 on me dit que
c'est sorti en 2006 la même année que
mass effect
bon bah au moins c'est un jeu français
bon normalement dans un gie dg je vous
parlerai même pas de ce genre de jeu
tellement c'est vide mais là je veux
juste noté la flemme incroyable des
développeurs qui sur certaines épreuves
n'ont même pas pris la peine de
modéliser les personnages je dire sur
l'escaladent par exemple tout se fait en
vue fps mais sans les bras
il ya juste un vague plans fixes des
fois pour te situer sur le mur qui
m'aiment et pareil pour certaines
épreuves je veux dire bon ok je veux
bien qu'en vrai ça soit impressionnant
il ya les insectes c'est bizarre c'est
dégueulasse tout ça met en jeu vidéo
on sent drôle ça marche pas même votre
personnage east en branle
mieux encore du temps ben toi enfin bon
il faut quand même que je vous montre la
salle du trésor et parce que là on
essaye même plus les personnages sont
même plus animée et si vous trouvez la
bonne réponse vous serez récompensé par
un très sobre
l'équipe est parvenue à libérer le
trésor oui et puis d'ailleurs vous savez
la partie où les gens ramassent tous les
boyards oui vous savez le moment de
l'émission nous a toujours pour ramasser
l'argent et côté trop haifa ce qu'est la
musique et tous ses biens à la place on
a ça
c'est génial
et après il ya un retour à l'écran titre
auteur photos et les citations tu a
triomphé des épreuves de fort boyard jeu
des années 90 il était bien mieux femmes
j'ai envie d'en dire du mal mais mais au
fond même pas parce qu'en fait je sais
très bien ce qui s'est passé dans le
studio à son nom la du développement et
grouillez-vous jeu il sort dans deux
heures oh [ __ ] et c'était vraiment
hoffenheim s'est tout simplement vagin
c'est quoi
je crois que les autres ont récupéré un
nouvel indice donc c'était bien
sympathique tard mais je vais y aller 1
mais rester s'il vous plaît non mais tu
arrives à ouais c'est ça tirez vos seins
toute façon le cas s'il est bon ok on
verra ça plus tard passons aux jo
suivants allaient aller plus vite plus
vite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok vous êtes prêt pour l'épreuve
suivante pourquoi vous avez fait courir
on est juste à côté de lui on était à 30
secondes florence vous êtes enceinte et
vous êtes totalement allergique
c'était preuve est faite pour vous bon
courage à florence bon allez florence
d'y aller j'ai passé à table ce soit
nuls à 12h10 tiempo et regarde en face
de toi ou on voit les yeux je suis
désolé je me suis trompé l'épreuve c'est
la porte juste derrière ici dans cette
zone c'est là où on met tous les animaux
entre deux émissions
c'est dangereux et ça explique pourquoi
il ya des tigres c'est pas une idée de
merde mais tous les animaux dans la même
pièce
c'est vrai je vais les faire et ça
semble évident quand on réalise un jeu
sur fort boyard de faire un jeu qui se
passe à l'intérieur du fort après tout
il ya déjà tout deux fait il ya des
épreuves d ahnif mon objectif c'est pour
ça que quand microids sort en 1996 un
jeu en fmb qui se passe autour du fort -
on peut reconnaître qu'ils ont des
couilles dans ce jeu on contrôle donc
cette personne qui sort du fort et qui
ressemble beaucoup trop adam presse de
tergnier le but du jeu étant donc de
retrouver un mystérieux trésor laissé
par napoléon le trésor qui m'intéressent
ne se trouve pas dans ses murs il est
bien cachée sur le site de fort boyard
au large au milieu de l'atlantique
c'est une vieille forteresse construite
sous napoléon qui sert maintenant de
cadre à la célèbre émission de
télévision fort boyard et au passage à
cette personne dira par le même enfer
que tous les gens qui portent des
lunettes de soleil en intérieur mais je
vais me forcer à oublier ça bref le jeu
commence juste avec un peu de pognon et
une folle envie d'aller aux toilettes
je sais pas pourquoi mais votre
personnage court il court tout le temps
d'aller tout le jeu je suis aller mater
tous les fichiers vidéo du jeu et même
sur des trajets de 4 m le mec qui
courent on se croirait dans le clip
darrouzès en forme
[Musique]
bref donc on arrive dans l'hôtel pour
parler aux types de l'accueil il sourit
beaucoup trop pour ne pas être sous
antidépresseurs alors ça c'est bien
passé sur formions oui notre équipe a
gagné 49 ans ça fait 8000 francs chacun
attendait mais c'était pas pour une
association
comme dans les jeux fmv classique de ce
genre là il faudra évidemment passé
beaucoup de temps à parler avec les
personnages que vous rencontrerez et y
croyez moi vu le talent des acteurs ça
vaut le coup de regarder ça qu'est ce
qu'il fait et elle qu'est ce qu'elle
fait sérieusement mais c'était quoi la
direction d'acteurs sur cette scène mon
ex femme
bref donc on peut parler à la demoiselle
au bar avec une conversation absolument
surréaliste
on se connaît
on fait déjà vu
je suis là non j'y suis mon crâne vous
l'adorez les parkings
donc après la conversation le barman
nous révèle l'identité de la dame et une
antiquaire c'est exactement comme ça que
je voyais les articles r aussi n'empêche
le dressing compte de l'hôtel du
commerce on dirait pas mais ça rigole
pas donc le barman vous raconte qu'il
possède justement une des pièces du
trésor de napoléon caisse c'est mon
grand père qui l'a ramenée souvenirs
tristes
et après avoir volé le dernier souvenir
familial d'un pauvre mec on va dormir et
hop flashback du vietnam avec
visiblement un des développeurs qui
était très content d'avoir trouvé
l'effet halo soit deux premières bref
d'embouts l'avez compris on a donc là un
jeu en fmb tout à fait classique le
gameplay tout à fait banal pour un jeu
de ce genre ya des items récupérés a
donné il ya plein de la ville des
discussions etc
en réalité si je vous parle de ce jeu
c'est pour son côté mais absurde
tout est surréaliste genre le lendemain
dans le jeu je retourne voir
l'antiquaire dans son magasin et quel
être humain au monde ça soit comme ça à
part pour lâcher une caisse regardez
cette scène comme voulu montrer la pièce
que vous avez ramassé la veille dans le
bar là
[Musique]
et c'est censé être une antiquaire ou
dimanche à l'heure ça va être quoi sa
prochaine apparition à quelqu'un c'est
pas déjà vu quelque part
bref alors je vais pas m'amuser à vous
faire le jeu en entier ensuite vous
allez au musée haut musée de la
soumission visiblement vu le look des
gardiens et là on commence à voir les
vrais soucis du jeu déjà premièrement
c'est que sans solution tu ne peux pas
trouver certains trucs genre tenait dans
l'hôtel comment est ce que je suis censé
devinez qui avait une mallette caché
sous le lit
c'est absurde rien de tôle indique et ça
amène à notre souci c'est que ce jeu
comme beaucoup de fmb se casse beaucoup
trop facilement dans ce genre de jeu à
vous avez en général un pattern de
dialogues bien précis à suivre pour
avancer et lorsque le jeu est réalisé un
peu à la va vite et bien vous vous
retrouvez rapidement dans une impasse où
tout est bloqué et où les événements ne
se déclenche plus genre par exemple si
vous n'avez pas trouvé cette mallette
qui est sous le lit pour ensuite aller
retirer de l'argent au distributeur
alors un pnj clé plus tard dans
l'histoire ne se montrera pas et ce même
si des deux éléments n'ont absolument
rien à voir l'un avec l'autre
rien vous avez l'argent attendez est-ce
que vous avez caresser le chien d'abord
oui et au passage je tiens à souligner à
quel point vous jouez une ordure et ça
n'est jamais mis en avant par le jeu non
parce que quand même vous incarner le
rôle d'un mec qui vient de gagner plein
de pognon à fort boyard qui arrive dans
un hôtel avec l'ambition de trouver un
trésor pour être encore plus riche
un pauvre gars vous montre son bien le
plus précieux légué par son grand-père
décédé vous de voler cinq minutes plus
tard et ensuite vous récupérer la carte
de crédit du type qui était dans la
chambre d'hôtel juste avant vous et
qu'il a oublié et vous allez vider son
compte en banque
bref alors je vais passer la première
partie de l'histoire qui se passe à la
rochelle et au bout d'un moment si vous
le souhaitez vous pourrez donc vous
diriger vers le fort avec l'aide d'un
des marins alors je prends lequel le
type qui a l'air louche tonton vin rouge
ou les mystères de pékin l'a acquis je
vais faire croire ça vous savez tout ce
qui je vais choisir
pour énorme et sur fort boyard
la mer est mauvaise l embarcation
fragile l'homme un peu d'argile un
souffle dans la glaise
comment pourra-t-il affronter la tempête
et le vent l'océan ses risques et périls
sans éprouver la terreur d'un enfant
oui mais du coup ça veut dire oui ou non
je vais être honnête en réalité ce
passage a été retiré du jeu en fait je
suis allé fouiller les fichiers du jeu
parce que bon on peut voir le type sur
un autre plan près du port et je me suis
dit qu'un asiatique déguisa ans bruce
lee qui fait du tai-chi sur le port je
suppose et que bon c'était pas un type
qui passait dans le champ de la caméra
par hasard j'ai pas été déçu car il
semble éprouver la paire eur d'un enfant
excusez moi mais tout ça pour moi c'est
du chinois
combien voulez vous pour nous emmener
sur fort boyard un grain de riz ainsi
parla l'empereur qin gang bang et un
grain de riz suffit à nourrir le pays le
compte y est honorable étriqué et bien
félicitations vous avez réussi le grand
combe aux déballeurs assiste cependant
vous auriez peut aussi faire une blague
par exemple sur la couleur jaune 1
alors ce geste qu'on fait avec les noms
ok alors ce que je vais dire à peut-être
l'air horrible mais croyez-moi ça l'est
pas mais heureusement qui avait pas de
noirs dans le jeu enfin bon du coup par
curiosité je suis allez donc sur twitter
pour demander à microïds des
développeurs du jeu de l'époque
pourquoi la scène en question avait été
supprimé et donc un type est d'aller
vérifier et il est jamais revenue
excusez moi sur twitter il ya un type
qui nous demandent pourquoi on a
supprimé l'extrait de l'asiatique dans
fort boyard
de quel extrait il parle
alors je vais pas vous raconter toute
l'histoire et vous détailler le moindre
pnj je vous dirais juste que j'ai passé
un excellent moment et que les espèces
de blanc beaucoup trop long qui à la fin
de chaque scène de dialogue me font
énormément rien jacqueline du rozel
vous me connaissez je rêve d'un film
tourné intégralement comme ça je suis
après au bout d'un moment je vais être
honnête ça devient juste casse couilles
quelqu'un a un chapeau et pas de tête et
un pied son soulier un cannibale tout un
champignon ta mère bon donc bref au bout
d'un certain temps vous finirez
finalement par arriver au fort boyard et
là le jeu change fini les dialogues à la
place vous aurez plusieurs épreuves et
c'est là où le jeu ne fait plus aucun
sens
enfin encore moins qu'avant je veux dire
le jeu commence en te disant que tu
reviens de l'émission fort boyard qui
sert maintenant de cadre à la célèbre
émission de télévision fort boyard
l'émission l'émission fort boyard ça
veut bien dire ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'il ya un caméraman ya des
acteurs il ya une équipe technique
externe
du coup quand le mec retourne fort là et
allez c'est reparti comme dans
l'émission
oui enfin là c'est pas l'émission c'est
une entrée par effraction c'est pareil à
l'intérieur tu croises donc les locaux
techniques de l'émission et en même
temps il ya le père fouras genre quoi tu
étais resté bloqué la foulée se
démaquiller maintenant il ya l'équipe
technique qui t'attend pour prendre le
bateau est d'ailleurs en réalité tout le
pilote de chemin tourne autour du père
fouras donc après avoir passé toutes les
énigmes etc
vous pourrez choisir à la fin
entreprendre les lingots d'or et prendre
un dictionnaire
voilà visiblement si vous choisissez les
lingots d'or ce qui est somme toute
logique parce qu'on a quand même volé le
souvenir d'enfance du barman ya quelques
heures je rappelle et bien baham votre
cupidité vous a fait tomber dans le
piège du père fouras ah bah oui au fait
parce que le père fouras et un [ __ ]
dans ce jeu vous saviez pas vous prenez
sa place et vous êtes maintenant
condamnés à errer dans le fort et a
tourné des émissions pour france 2
[ __ ] c'est complètement con et c'est
bon j'ai l'indicé gars allaient alors
c'est le mot bits et ben ça vole pas
haut le jdg maintenant à voilà dix-sept
florent s'est passé c'était oui non sauf
le lundi c'est quoi lundi ce que je te
dis c'était dur sans pas les couilles au
sommaire de l'émission c'est quoi c'est
dur la vie nickel vous avez à présent
tous les indices il vous reste 30
secondes pour trouver le mot vous avez
des idées dit je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez utiliser un sacrifice pour
obtenir un indice supplémentaire
tu vas oui oui la musique mérite sa
cuisine et moi les gars c'est pour les
patek
ouais c'est pas exactement ce que
j'avais en tête mais bon on florence
vous n'avez pas tout perdu voilà l'un 10
il s'agit du mot enfant comme celui que
vous allez et lever tout seuls
pas forcément pour écouter les gars les
indices on habite dur vagin et enfants
vous avez des idées non c'est pas
hôpital saint nabor colibri pygargues
acouphènes beat dur je sais j'ai une
idée nouvelle confiance
non vous avez d'autres idées non alors
on y va
n e c'est l'une des têtes de tigres et
oui nos candidats ont bel et bien vu
juste c'était la réponse correcte
l'ânesse la célèbre console de nintendo
premier indice dit parce que c'est une
console 8 bits dur parce qu'elle a
hésité pour avoir un catalogue de jeux
extrêmement difficile enfants parce que
c'est une console microsoft pour qui
pour les enfants et enfin bajdar parce
que c'est de là que les enfants naissent
ses premiers safer fin d'argent pour les
handicapés premiers savants fait rouler
pour eux de traiter à continuer bayou le
conte
[Musique]
ça veut dire qu pour rester du goût
voir
[Rires]
[Musique]